-You know our first guest
tonight from his movie,
"The King of Staten Island,"
and, of course,
his work
on "Saturday Night Live,"
which returns this week
with host Elon Musk
and musical guest Miley Cyrus.
He stars in the Audible podcas
"Hit Job,"
available now
exclusively on Audible.
Please welcome back to the show,
our very good friend,
Pete Davidson, everybody.
♪♪♪♪
[ Applause ]
-Yeah.
-Get in there!
-What's up, bro?
What's up, bro?
-Good to see you, buddy.
-Elbow bumps.
'Sup, crew?
Hey, Wally.
I sit--
-Is it exciting
for you to see Wally?
-I love Wally.
-Yeah.
-I try to steal his cue card
every night before goodnights.
-Oh, the last set?
-Yeah, I started doing it
a few years ago,
and I successfully did it once
-Really?
-Yeah.
-But doesn't that seem to be
a crime you're perpetratin
on the host, because they're
the one that needs to read
the cue cards at the end?
-Wow. I guess
I'm very selfish, Seth.
[ Laughter ]
-Last we talked this --
this summer,
you were in your mom's basement.
-Yes.
-I believe, like everyone
who's ever met your mom,
huge fan of hers.
-Great lady.
-Great lady. But are you happy
to be out of the basement?
Although I should note,
the basement looked pretty nice.
There seemed to be multipl
computer -- video-game consoles.
-[ Laughs ]
Thank you!
-So, I didn't --
-No, I would just like peopl
to know that, like,
I bought that house, too.
Like, I --
-That's -- okay.
That's a very --
-Yeah. Like, I set up --
It was sick down there.
-Yeah.
-Like, people would come over,
and they'd be like,
"Oh, this is sick."
-Yes. I think it was actually --
We --
It was a service to everyone
to see how nice
the situation was.
Because I think we use
"mom's basement"...
-Right.
-...sort of to be derogatory
but in your case,
I mean, that's like somethin
everybody should be aiming for
-Yeah. It was like --
it was really cool.
But it was also --
It's nice to move out
because it's really nice
to masturbate
and not hear your mom,
like, cooking.
-Yeah.
-You know?
-Except for, like,
a very thin slice of people.
-Yeah.
-Who it's --
-Some people --
Well, that was my fear.
It was like, "What if I like -
that's the only way
I can finish now?"
[ Laughter ]
-So you, like, call her up
-I'm like, "Hey!
What are you doing right now?"
"I'm cooking."
I'm like, "Oh, great."
-Oh, no!
[ Laughter ]
We knew what it looked like!
-Sorry.
[ Laughter ]
I'm a very simple man.
-Hey, it's -- We were
talking to Che yesterday.
Challenging season for "SNL,
certainly,
but a really good season.
Have you enjoyed yourself?
-This has been
my favorite season.
I don't know.
The pandemic has kind of -
It really made me
very appreciative of things.
-Mm-hmm.
-It was 'cause
it was such a kick in the nuts
And so, I've been having a blast
and just been feeling so lucky
to have a place go and wor
and be funny,
'cause the world's so nuts
You know?
-And, you know, obviously,
it's about half of what
a normal "SNL" audience is
but when you were doing show
for, you know, zero
or a little bit more than zero
it must feel like a full house
-Yeah. No, yeah.
It's like 50% full.
But the energy's great
'cause everybody's, again,
so excited to be out.
And, you know,
we're having a really fun time
-You did a couple of
Eminem-inspired
sketches this year.
-Yes, we did.
-And there's one.
-Yeah.
-There's another. And you go
to talk to him on the phone.
-Yes.
-How'd it go?
-It went I think
as good as it could go.
Those were written by the grea
Dan Bulla and Steven Castillo,
great "SNL" writers.
And they -- and Redd.
And we -- I was -- Eminem said
a couple nice things, like
about me, and I,
of course, heard them.
And I reached out, I was like,
"I would just like
to say thank you."
And I just hit him up.
I said, "Thanks."
And he was like, "Yeah, man.
He was like, "You really -
you really did that."
He's like, "When I saw
Stu on script, I was like,
'I don't know how
it was gonna go.'
But, like, after you did that,
it was fire."
And I was like,
"Oh, thank you so much!
You're the coolest."
And then I just hung up
as quick as possible.
-I know that feeling.
-That's all you need.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You don't want to --
anything more.
-You don't want to extend --
When you talk to a hero,
you don't want to extend it.
If you're good, get out.
-Yeah, get out
as soon as you can, yeah.
[ Both laugh ]
It's like the stock market
-I remember my first year
on the show,
Bruce Springsteen --
maybe it was my second year,
I went up to him.
And I did that thing that --
You know, I know he's heard it
a million times.
I just had to say it.
-You have to do it.
-Right. And I said,
"I just wanted to say,
I'm a huge fan.
It's so cool to meet you,"
and he was very polite,
and he was like, "Cool, man.
How's the -- How's the sho
gonna be this week?"
And I just said, "Bye!"
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
I'm like, "I don't -- let's not.
This doesn't have to be
a conversation."
-Yeah. I didn't know
you were that cool.
[Bleep]"
-I didn't have a plan.
-Yeah.
-Elon Musk this week.
-Yes.
-I'm guessing, by the day,
you haven't met him yet,
or you have?
-I haven't met him yet.
I'm having dinner
with him tonight.
-Oh, that's exciting.
-And Lorne.
So I will meet him.
I'm really excited, man.
I hope -- I'm gonna ask hi
for like a Tesla or some [bleep]
-Yeah.
-Why not?
Be like, "Hey,
Mother's Day's coming up.
You know, my mom would -- yo
know, it would be cool if --
-Now if he gave it to you,
would you then feel obligate
to give it to your mom...
-Well --
-...since you very much implie
by that that it would be a gift.
-Well, I would disguise it as
gift for my mom so he gives it
and then, as soon
as she drives it once or twice
I would take it.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Yeah.
-Two questions --
would you go to space
if he asked you?
-100%.
-Would you get stoned with him
if he asked you?
-100,000%.
[ Laughter ]
That guy's a ge--
I don't know why --
People are freaking out.
They're like,
"Oh, I can't believe that
Elon Musk is hosting."
And I'm like, "The guy tha
makes the Earth better kind of
And he makes cool things
and sends people to Mars?"
-You wouldn't be worried
about going to Mars?
-No.
I mean, like --
You know, after the pandemic
I want to go sky diving.
-Yeah.
-Mars sounds great, too.
-Yeah, you know, Earth didn'
crush it during the pandemic
-Yeah.
-As it turns out,
we're very susceptible
to disease.
-Yeah.
-This is a podcast you did
with the wonderful Keke Palmer
-Yes.
-And you actually worked on this
during the pandemic.
-Yes. This was amazing,
'cause I was, you know,
trapped in my mom's basement
for like six months.
And then, Broadway Video,
you know, Lorne's company,
they -- they started doing
these Audible originals.
And they were like,
"Would you like to do one
with Keke Palmer?"
I was like, "Absolutely.
That sounds amazing."
-Can you --
Can you say enough nice things
about voiceover work?
I mean, it's the way to go
right?
-It's the way to go,
because if it doesn't work out
your face isn't on it.
-Yep.
-You know?
-That's true.
Nobody's ever like,
"I can't look at that guy
after his bad podcast."
-Yeah.
No -- It's -- Yeah, it's a great
thing because it doesn't matter.
Not saying
this thing doesn't matter.
But if it goes bad,
it'll be fine for me.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, yeah, they probably
won't put that on the poster
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, you're not known --
I mean, again, it's one thin
to play Eminem.
Obviously that's somebody that
you know, you're developin
an impression of them
whether or not you know it
because you've been listenin
to him your whole life.
-Right.
-You also played Governor Cuomo.
I'm assuming you did not hav
a Cuomo in your back pocket.
-No, believe it or not,
I'm not usually the guy
they go to for impersonations...
-Yeah.
-...on "SNL."
I've been there for seven years.
I don't think I've ever
done a guy --
Yeah, usually I'm the guy
that they're like,
"Hey, at, you know,
two minutes into the sketch,
can you walk by in the
background and be like, 'Gyah!'"
[ Laughter ]
And I got used to that role.
You know, as Wally knows,
I'm the color brown
on the cue cards.
[ Laughter ]
-And I --
-Wally!
-And I went up --
No, for seven years,
and I went up to Wally,
and I was like,
"Hey, am I brown?"
'Cause, like, other people pic
different colors or whatever
and he's like, "No, that's -
that's just
the last color we use."
[ Laughter ]
But he changed it
for me this year.
This year, he changed it.
It was really sweet.
And now I don't --
I think I have blue,
which makes me feel better
But, yeah, I found out, like
maybe that day,
like eight hours before,
they were like,
"You're gonna play Cuomo."
-That's a pretty good --
I mean, did you find --
I mean, obviously, you're
regionally close to Cuomo.
-Yeah, it's a New York --
It's not much of a stretch
[ Laughter ]
Like, I'm not
doing anything special.
But, you know, it's --
it's a pretty easy one to do
-This one is very exciting
and also regionally close
for you.
-Right.
-A little bit maybe more
of a stretch.
I guess the weird thing is
you wouldn't think of Cuom
and Joey Ramone as the same,
but the same guy who's gonna
play him in a movie.
You're writing a movie
about Joey Ramone based on a -
on a book.
-Yeah.
So, my pal Jason Orley,
who did "Big Time Adolescence,
we're teaming up, and we're just
writing the story by.
And then, you know,
we're gonna --
someone's gonna take it
and turn it into a movie.
And, yeah, either a really great
or horrible choice by a studio
[ Laughter ]
And we will find out.
-Now, one thing
your burgeoning film caree
has led you to decide...
-Yes.
-...is the removal of your
famous tattoo collection.
-Oh, God.
Yeah.
So, I didn't think that
they would put me in stuff
-Like the movie business.
-Like movie business
or anything.
I thought after this, "SNL,"
I thought it was a wrap.
[ Laughter ]
But --
-Because again, you starte
"SNL" when you were 20.
-Yeah.
-And you thought it was gonna be
your last job?
-Yeah.
Well, people don't realize
I'm kind of old.
I'm like 27, but in Hollywood,
that's like 40.
-Yeah.
That would make me 100.
-It's like --
It's like, you know,
a basketball player
being like 37.
So -- no, I just --
I honestly never thought
that I would get
an opportunity to act,
and I love it a lot.
And it takes three hours.
You have to get there
three hours earlier
to cover all your tattoos
'cause for some reason,
people in movies, they don't
have them that much.
-Right.
And you basically used your on
sort of autobiographical
type movie --
-Yeah.
-You've used that bullet.
Did "King of Staten Island."
And then you had to figure out
how to --
-So now I'm burning them off
But, like, burning them of
is worse than getting them
Because not only are they, like,
burning off your skin,
but you're wearing
these big goggles, right?
So you can't see anything.
And there's just, like --
the doctor's in there with you
So before he goes
to laser each tattoo,
you have to hear him announc
what the tattoo is,
to make sure if you
want to keep it or not.
So I'll just be sitting there,
you know, all high
off of the Pro-Nox,
which I actually quite enjoy
It's actually pretty fun.
And then, all of a sudden,
I'll just hear,
"Are we keeping
the Stewie Griffin
smoking a blunt?"
[ Laughter ]
And then I have to sit there
and be like, "No, Dr. G."
And he's like, "All right.
And then gz-gz-gz-gz-gz!
[Bleep]
But, yeah, if you're gonna
get tattoos, you know,
just make sure
you really, really want it
-Yeah.
-And aren't on mushrooms.
-'Cause it's not -- I thin
that's a really important lesson
is it's not just that one da
you'll have them taken off
You will have to have them
audibly described to you
by a medical professional.
-Yeah, it's really embarrassing.
[ Laughter ]
"Are we keeping the owl
that licks the Tootsie Pop?"
[ Laughter ]
"Yes, actually,
we are keeping that one."
[ Laughter ]
-That is a keeper.
-That one's a keeper.
-Hey, buddy, thank you so much
for being here.
It is always such a pleasure
-Thanks, man.
-Congrats on the podcast.
And more importantly,
congrats on another
fantastic season of "SNL."
-Thank you, bro.
-Seven years. Seven years.
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
-"Hit Job" is available no
on Audible.
Here it is one more time.
There it is.
And, yeah, "SNL" returns
this week with host Elon Mus
and musical guest Miley Cyrus.